- Since last September
Patricia has been working
at the convenience store down the road.
So we have to think about
what they've underlined
right over here, this has been working.
Do we want to go with that?
And the first choice is always exactly
as they wrote it right over here.
So they wrote, has been working.
They wrote has been working over there.
So do we want to go
with it as it's written,
which is always going
to be the first choice,
or do we think one of these other choices
is going to make more sense?
So since last September
Patricia has been working
at the convenience store down the road.
Well, has been working
actually looks pretty good,
looks pretty good, because
we're not talking about
something that just
happened in the past tense.
So if this is last, so this
is a timeline right over here,
and if this is last September,
she starts working last September,
but then she keeps
working since, since then.
So we want something that is both,
that starts in the past
but then keeps going
on through the future.
And so, that's what has
been working does for us.
Now let's think about the other choices
and see why they don't quite do that.
So if we used works, works
is the present tense.
That would mean that she's
only doing it right now.
It doesn't mean that she's been doing it
starting at some period in the past
and continuing to do it all
the way through right now.
So if we said since last September
Patrica works at the
convenience store down the road,
then we essentially have
the verb tense wrong,
because this is starting
in the past and continuing,
while this is just the present.
Since last September Patricia is working
at the convenience store down the road.
So once again, this one is
talking about the present,
while we want something
that starts in the past
and then continues through the present.
So this one is only the present.
Since last September
Patricia will be working.
Well this is now occurring in the future,
and that's not what since last September
is trying to talk about.
Since last September, we
want to go to the past
into the present.
So we will throw out that.
Will be working kind of implies that,
well, we're really
talking about the future.
And since last September Patricia worked.
So this is strictly the past.
It's not really talking about the past
and continuing through the present.
So since last September Patricia worked.
That's kind of like, hey, she had worked,
and maybe she's not working anymore,
but we want to convey that
she started working then,
and she's continuing to work.
So has been working seems
to make the most sense.